I did it if you've been following this
channel for a while you'll know that
I've been struggling with some computer
code for a while about 18 months
actually and it was putting a real
question mark over whether or not I
could finish my thesis in time so this
video is going to be about what the
problem with the code was and how I
fixed it but also if you follow me on
Twitter you'll know that I have a
promise to keep to understand that why
this code was such an issue you first
need to understand why I was using
computer code in the first place I
actually get quite a lot of comments
asking me you know why am i doing coding
are not computer science PhD I'm a
atmospheric physics PhD the reason is
that I work on the biggest experiment in
the world it is the atmosphere it's the
size of the planet there's no way that I
could do a physical experiment on the
atmosphere that would test my hypothesis
while I could go in and fiddle with the
temperature and the velocity there's
simply no way of doing it so we have to
simulate it in a computer we basically
take data from the real world from
satellite observations and from surface
observations we put them in a computer
and then we let things like the
temperature and velocity and the
humidity in the air evolve by equations
that we understand that we know how to
apply so we build a fake earth in the
computer and the way that we interact
with that is through computer code so
that's why I was doing this now the
specific codes that I was working on of
course no the problem was doing
something called potential vorticity
inversion and I've actually made a whole
video about what that is and what it
means which you can check out in the
description but the brief version is
that tension for tissa t or pv for sure
is a super useful composite variable and
by that I mean it takes in information
from pressure temperature and how
quickly the air is moving in the
atmosphere and it combines all of that
stuff into one field so instead of
having a pressure field a temperature
field a velocity field you have a
potential vorticity field
now we know how pressure and temperature
and velocity evolve over time it's just
that the equations that describes that
are very complicated and sometimes
they're just completely impractical to
simulate on a computer whereas the
equation that describes how PV evolve is
really simple so what you do is you take
your fields you've lost in your
temperature whatever and you bind it up
into your PV field into a PV blob and
then you know how that blobs going to
evolve very easily so you add vector you
move it into the future and then you
unpack the fields from the PV in a
process called
inversion so you go from having
knowledge of the fields like pressure
and temperature at one time to having
knowledge of what they're going to be at
a future time without having to work
with nasty equations so what my code did
was take a given PV field and then
invert it to give the Associated
velocity temperature and pressure fields
except it did I've been looking forward
to doing this for a long time so my K
wasn't doing a good job inverting a
given PV distribution and giving
temperature and velocity and pressure
fields and you can test that by looking
at observations so we have observations
of pressure of temperature of velocity
in the atmosphere and we also have
observations of PV so you compare the
output of the inverted PV the observed
PV you output the inverted temperature
and you compare that temperature field
for the whole planet to the observed
temperature field and those two fields
in my case just didn't match up now I'll
give you the main problem was the fact
that there are so many links in the
chain to working out what's gone wrong
because you don't know if for some
reason the field that you're comparing
it to let's say temperature you don't
have a temperature field that you're
comparing your output to is correct
it might be wrong you don't know if
you're calculating the temperature from
the output of your inverter correctly
you might be doing that wrong
most likely the techniques they were
using to invert the PV might be wrong
you might be applying them wrong and
then lastly the PV data that you put
into the inverter in the first place
might be wrong plus then you can add
into the mix simple programming errors
which was the case for a couple of
months but when you move beyond the
simple technical errors there's just a
quagmire of different things and
different threads you have to pick apart
and there's no obvious answer here it is
God I think if we just like bring it out
[Music]
domestic goddess sam'l at work
you wouldn't tap it the Trinity never
give it what for the only way to work
out what was going wrong was simply to
try stuff to substitute in different
inputs and different temperature
comparing it to try on different dates
the problem was that the inverter was
slow it took a long time to work
actually I need to explain exactly what
it was doing so the inverter works by
inverting the qgp the equation that's
the quasi zero potential vorticity
equation which looks like this and it
would invert it through a process called
successive over relaxation which is an
iterative technique meaning that the
more iterations you put it in the more
iterations you allow this technique to
go through the more accurate your answer
will be and the idea is that you put in
a given accuracy you say keep going
until this accuracy is reached and then
it will stop running the problem was I
needed to do at least a few hundred if
not thousand iterations and when I first
wrote the program it took several
seconds for each iteration now when you
add that up to several hundred
iterations or several thousand
iterations it was just criminally slow
so the first key step forward in solving
this problem was taking everything I'd
written in Python which is my standard
language and rewriting it in Fortran
which
is a specialist technical language is
actually quite archaic doing the sped
things up by a factor of a thousand and
actually allowed me to do what I did
subsequently so armed with this new
super fast code I was able to try
everything and look at every link in the
chain from the data put in at the start
to the final comparison to atmospheric
data and basically work backwards from
the end to the beginning and I found
that the problem was in the very first
link in the chain literally I don't here
you go take so much pleasure
well it's nearly killing the fire like
it nearly killed me I should probably
let it cool first shouldn't I cool it in
the barbecue yeah yeah are you gonna go
I said I do oh oh yeah then let it cool
girl I suddenly realize what you meant
oh that yeah that's a good idea
this is getting into the really
nitty-gritty technical stuff now but
basically the PV if you like is a
measure of the twisting of the
atmosphere it's a measure the vorticity
multiplied by a certain thickness which
depending on the approximation you use
well actually that's too much detail for
this video but basically there are
multiple ways of looking at PV and
there's the qgp v which is what that
equation was I showed you before which
may look complicated but it's actually
got a bunch of approximations built into
it and then there's the full proper PV
which is the TEL PV which may look
simpler but that's because I found up a
whole bunch of stuff into the Sigma
underneath and the real problem was I
was trying to convert from one form to
the other and you just can't because the
data file which is supplied on the
internet for PV on a given day is a tell
PV that's you know the true value and I
was trying to convert that to qg PV by
getting it into the right unit and a
whole bunch of other factors which on
paper look like it should work and it
was a detail in one of my workbooks that
I just sort of Aragon yeah this is how
you do it this is definitely right and
it wasn't you can't do that so what I
did was I had the equation for the qg pv
and i had the required field like the
velocity and the temperature which they
used to calculate sy the stream function
and i just made my own pv I put Simon's
qgp V through Simon's inverter and lo
and behold the correct temperature
pressure velocity fields came out at the
end
inadvertently I actually created a
fantastic coat because I work backwards
through the chain only finding the error
at the very beginning which meant I
knocked every pillar that held up the
temple of this program and kept smashing
until it was you know exactly what it
needed to be there was no fat on the
bone and did that all the way through
into the data info which meant that when
I put my data through I created it was
really fast and really good if you were
to give me this problem tomorrow it
would not take 18 months to solve
because I had 20/20 hindsight I know
exactly what went wrong at the time
there are so many variables so many
things which could go wrong and so many
question marks about how I was testing
what was going wrong but in addition to
the fact that I'm a relatively novice
programmer at least I was eighteen
months ago there's all kind of reasons
why this took so long but what matters
now to me is that it's done I went on to
a PhD straight from being at Oxford and
in my fourth year my finally at Oxford I
had basically a breakdown I had a huge
mental health issue and I consequently
did really Paul in my fourth year and
this problem to me seemed indicative of
what went wrong then it was like I'm
just not good enough I don't know what
I'm doing are not real scientists and so
for this problem - suddenly work for me
to work out on my own with you know help
along the way but the final solution -
all working out what was going wrong I
did it and
I can't begin to tell you how much that
meant because for me this was the
victory that I needed and I waited for
for new for years and it proved to me
that I wasn't a failure and that I was a
scientist I knew what I was doing and so
when I made the final change to the code
press ENTER it ran and my predictor
fields matched up with the observed
fields I had to throw really hard not
just a breakdown crying I've never cried
in joy ever in my life until this works
I left my desk I went to the nearest
bathroom and I sobbed my eyes out
throughout five minutes because I was
just so happy I'd never felt that kind
of happiness before because it was a
victory over my demons it was something
I desperately needed I got home and I
cried some more and I turned into a
massive softy for about 12 hours because
I got the monkey off my back
I showed that you know what
you know that done what a blacktop I
wasn't I thought I kept I'm a a black
top probably wasn't the best idea it was
it no so the plan now is I've got a
little bit over two months to finish off
my thesis with this code working and
athletes and what I just finished today
another little sort of speed bump with a
different set of code now those two
things are locked in place and let me
know they work really well now it's kind
of a question of just putting data in
turning the crank and getting output in
a way I could get a thesis chapter
written in a week now which then leaves
me a long time to get a final chapter
building on those results put together
with more data runs nothing that I'm
gonna be doing is anywhere newest
complex in terms of like writing new
code then the problems I've been having
so fingers crossed it's going to be a
much smoother ride very fast right but a
much smoother ride to the finish line
than you know the past couple of months
have been if you've been following me
throughout the saga of my P V inversion
code and thank you for sticking around
because honestly having having this vlog
having having you guys as an audience
defense to keep things in perspective
and like therapy has been honestly more
useful than you could know so thank you
for sticking it out on the other hand if
you're new here hello I'll include a
link up here to a playlist of all the
vlogs that I've done over the past year
or so my PhD you might want to check
them out if you enjoyed this video and
they'll also be buttoned down there to
subscribe if you like thank you for
watching and the next couple of logs
will be me finishing off my PhD that's
Gary